i'll give you a perfect example of this
came out of the nba
now you'll be shocked to hear i don't
know very much about the nba i don't
follow the league
particularly closely however actually
the only sport i ever followed closely
was baseball and now i can't do that
because they disrespect the national
anthem but i looked a little bit into
the nba
have you ever heard of a player for the
orlando magic named jonathan
isaac something tells me that
even if you are a basketball fan you
might not know who that guy is
the reason that i mention him is because
as
of right now he is selling more jerseys
than anybody in the nba
other than lebron james how's that
possible
well the reason is jonathan isaac is the
only guy on his team
who had the colioni to stand up for the
national anthem
he stands up for the national anthem all
the other players kneel
the whole league kneels down they accept
the premises of the radical left black
lives matter
they attack the national anthem the
symbol of our country
they did that presumably because they
thought that's what everybody wanted to
see that's that's where the mass the
majority of people were right wrong
the one guy who stands up his jersey
sales go through the roof even though
very few people have heard of him
why because there it now
look obviously there's the silent
majority are all these nba fans going to
vote for
donald trump i don't know i don't and
i'm not i'm not even saying this
just because the nba has a
disproportionately black
audience and black voters
disproportionately don't like donald
trump right i'm not doing
what the left does and divvying this
down strictly on the basis of race
but i'm thinking of sports in general a
lot of people who watch sports
have sports you know people who don't
watch sports treat politics as sports
that's kind of what we do
but people who watch sports very often
they're just not that politically
involved
so are they going to vote for trump are
they going to vote for biden because
they're not paying attention are they
not going to vote at all
that's the question what we do know
though is trump's got to get those guys
trump's got to get the guys who are
buying the jerseys of jonathan
isaac i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you